et en direct pour évoquer le dossier
ukrainien et les sanctions occidentales
en vue contre la russie sur ce plateau
l'analyste politique nicholas markowitz
bonjour bonjour vous êtes président de
l'association ouest est ce qu'ils
oeuvrent de manière humanitaire dans le
donbass et puis vous avez également
écrit le livre l'amérique empire aux
éditions temporis
comment est-ce que vous réagissez aux
premières sanctions qui viennent de
tomber de l'allemagne qui suspend donc
le gazoduc north stream ii et puis
également la grande bretagne qui
sanctionne cinq banques russes est
également trois personnes influentes en
russie j'hallucine ou peut-être que je
ne devrais pas halluciné quand on pense
à ce que les puissances occidentales en
et de l'ouest sont en train de
dire ce soir où étaient les sanctions de
ou du royaume uni de l'allemagne de la
france quand l'azerbaïdjan attaquer le
haut karabagh ou des télés sanctions
contre la turquie que la turquie a
envoyé illégalement la syrie où étaient
les sanctions du monde entier ou même de
l'onu quand les états unis ont bombardé
la syrie où quand l'otan a bombardé
illégalement la yougoslavie en 1999 sans
autorisation du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies et qui ont détruit toute
l'infrastructure de la yougoslavie c2c
ce deux poids deux mesures qui montre à
quel point je pense les pays occidentaux
seraient en train de se comporter
vraiment eux mêmes comme des pays voyous
n'arrête pas dénoncer les voyous et on
voit que le bas il ya des sanctions qui
sont sélectives selon l'endroit selon la
zone selon l'intérêt géopolitique et
bien ils vont appliquer des sanctions ou
pas là on voit qu'il est tout une mesure
de sanction je pense que ce n'est pas
une surprise pour la russie elle
s'attendait évidemment à ces sanctions
et nous savons que les dernières dernier
volet de sanctions qu'on voit depuis ces
dernières années en tout cas de la part
des pays membres de l'otan contre la
russie n'ont visiblement pas beaucoup
d'effets non pas en tout cas pas autant
d'effets espérer des des articles de
presse de bloomer ou des financial times
la teste donc j'ai curieux de savoir
jusqu'où les pays membres de l'otan vont
aller pour appliquer d'autres sanctions
à la russie justement d'ici quelques
instants on attend à la conférence de
presse
de jean yves le drian le ministre
français des affaires étrangères est
également du chef de la diplomatie
européenne recettes borel du côté du
quart du quai d'orsay à quoi est ce que
vous attendez il ya un bal est organisé
chacun va arriver avec sa liste de
sanctions donc ça va être peut-être
contre eux quelques quelques zones
d'influencé contre quelques sociétés
c'est la même litanie depuis depuis 2014
j'ai envie de dire si seulement les
efforts concentrés par toutes ces
puissances occidentales pour mettre en
place des sanctions avaient été mises en
place plutôt pauvre oeuvrer pour la paix
au donbass on n'en serait certainement
pas là j'hallucine vraiment de voir
toutes ces pays qui est vraiment tous
ces pays qui cherchent à faire du mal à
la russie ce soir qui n'a fait que
reconnaître des républiques
indépendantes n'y a pas une bombe qui a
été envoyé et à rien c'est pas comme le
temps en 1999 en serbie au kosovo
pourquoi est ce que toute cette énergie
n'est pas déployés pour la paix au nom
basque et pourquoi est-ce qu'on a dû
attendre huit ans depuis huit ans alors
il ya cette guerre au donbass et on voit
pas la france ou l'allemagne devraient
pour mettre en place des sanctions
contre kiev qui ne revoit pas sa
constitution comme elle avait prévu dans
les accords de minsk 2 qui ne retire pas
son artillerie lourde comme avait prévu
dans les accords de minsk de donc du
coup il ya l'hypocrisie dans tout ça je
pense que ça justifie aussi en tout cas
ça explique voilà les accords de minsk
sont morts les accords sombre des
accords sont ceux morts mais rien n'a
été fait ça fait depuis 2015 que cet
accord sont en place sont en place
pourquoi est ce que les chancelleries
occidentales pourquoi ce que washington
n'a pas utilisé cette même énergie
qu'elle emploie pour mettre en place des
sanctions pour mettre en place les
accords de minsk de hong kong pensent
peut-être que les pays occidentaux les
pays membres de l'otan n'ont jamais
vraiment cru dans ces accords de paix de
2005 de la seule chose qui intéresse
washington c'est clairement une zone de
tensions sur la frontière russe et on
voit ce soir que malheureusement je
pense qu'il y a qu'à washington qu'on se
frotte les mains ce soir parce que ils
vont avoir une partie de ce qu'il
voulait c'est à dire plus de sanctions
contre la russie sont tous les cas en
attend un les les mesures de washington
dans la journée par le washington tu
fais partie donc du g7 est d'ailleurs le
g7 à l'instant apporte son soutien je
cite inébranlable à l'intégrité
territoriale de l'ukraine comment est-ce
que vous accueillez cette déclaration
c'est un groupe de pays atlantiste donc
du coup ils vont dans le même sens et il
attend les ordres de washington ils vont
ensuite une fois que washington a dit ce
qu'il fallait dire ils vont tous à l'eau
et la même phrase dans le même sens
pareil où était le g7 quand la turquie a
envahi le nord de la syrie où était le
g7 qu'ont les etats unis ont bombardé
les sirènes également quand ils ont
bombardé
quand ils ont bombardé sont arrivés en
afghanistan même si c'était plus ou
moins autorisées par l'onu les crimes de
guerre commis par les pays membres de
l'otan en afghanistan en irak au niveau
de la vie où était le g7 pour les
condamner pour demander au moins que les
responsables et coupables le site crimes
de guerre soient jugés il n'était pas là
donc que ce soir ils aillent dans le
même sens que l'otan que les états unis
n'étaient absolument pas surprenants
hélas basse on a entendu nicolas
mircovich doran abderrazik parler de de
l'aide humanitaire vous qui travaillez
justement dans l'humanitaire vis-à-vis
du donbass avec votre association ouest
est commencée ce que ça s'organise tout
ça c'est une situation assez compliquée
bon là on voit maintenant que les
républiques du dombass ont l'habitude ça
fait maintenant depuis 2000 quatorze qui
sont dans cette situation avec moi je
suis arrivé seul à mener des premières
missions humanitaires dès 2014 pendant
la guerre ses premières années c'est
évidemment compliqué vous ne vous
attendez pas sa personne dans la région
s'attendent à ce qu'ils aient une guerre
quelques mois auparavant donc du coup
vous battre vous débrouillez vous
adaptez l'homme fait preuve de beaucoup
de suivre dit subtilités de créativité
dans c'est dans ces moments là pour
faire le bien et pour essayer
d'organiser l'aide humanitaire mais tel
est plusieurs fois ce qu'il faut c'est
évidemment des des réseaux et là on voit
qu'ils aient beaucoup dette qui arrive
de la part de la russie de
l'organisation de la logistique les
camions l'approvisionnement en
alimentation en nourriture en eau est
extrêmement importante on voit aussi que
l'aide russe et à des grues sabbath
assez importante dans la dans la région
mais aussi que les républiques ont su
s'organiser les républiques de donetsk
de doullens elles mêmes ont des centres
d'approvisionnement est elle-même en
organiser l'acheminement des personnes
par train par quart parce qu'il ya des
organisations de services d'urgence de
ces deux républiques faut pas oublier
que ce sont pas juste des républiques
qui sont nées du jour en main ça fait
huit ans qu'ils sont organisés ils ont
leurs papiers dans leur administration
et lviv cancer en situation de guerre
tout le temps depuis 2014 donc du coup
elles sont habituées et cet acheminement
des aides humanitaires et cet
acheminement d'autant de personnes ont
si peu de temps de le coter la frontière
montre que les ballets de la république
quand une organisation et logistique à
qui et qui est prête à pour tous les
déportés les épreuves en tous les cas
les
les informations tombent beaucoup en
tout temps de cette journée par exemple
du côté de là aussi le sénat approuve le
déploiement de soldats du côté de
donetsk de lougansk
comment est-ce que vous accueillez 7 ce
vote cette approbation je pense qu'il
faut pas oublié la finalité de tout cela
c'est pas une reconnaissance politique
pour agrandir le territoire au pouvoir
reconnaître la nouvelle indépendance la
guillotine a dit aujourd'hui qu'il ne
voulait pas reconstituer un empire
exactement c'est pas le but le but c'est
la paix la lumière poutine l'a rappelé
l'objectif c'est la paix c'est parce que
les accords de minsk 2 n'ont pas
fonctionné qui a toujours ces situations
de guerre je pense que la russie a dit
nous mais non vous à venir que ça veut
dire que c'était inéluctable ça
prise de parole et sa décision d'hier
oui au bout d'un moment s'il avait voulu
faire leur effet plutôt 6 la russie a pu
reconnaître que c'est serré public dès
2014 et les référendums dans les deux
républiques oui ou non voulez-vous
l'autonomie voulez-vous l'indépendance
il est vrai public ont majoritairement
voté pour ce n'est pas la république à
cette époque là les régions ont voté
pour ce sont devenus des républiques
suite à des référendums si la russie
voulait les reconnaître plus tôt il
aurait pu le faire pendant cette période
sur ces huit dernières années et ne l'a
pas fait c'est le fait maintenant c'est
parce que les accords de minsk de ne
fonctionne pas n'oublions pas qu'il ya
aussi des exercices de l'otan qui se
rapprocher la russie la russie qui a
demandé de signer deux traités et avec
le temps et avec les états unis des
traités de paix parce qu'il dise qui est
une menace pour leur sécurité et les
états unis et l'otan en renvoyer ces
traités p non seulement ils ont renvoyé
des traités p donc c'est la voie la main
tendue par moscou mais en plus ces
derniers mois on a vu beaucoup de
soldats craignant s'amasser sur la ligne
de front et les pays membres de l'otan
qui acheminent des armes télé ce message
que donnent les pays occidentaux qui se
soit en train de se précipiter sur des
sanctions quel est le message que d'un
côté ils disent qu'ils veulent la paix
ils envoient des sanctions mais qu'ils
acheminent des armes massivement à
l'armée ukrainienne s'il envoie toutes
ses armes ses portes quelques ailes dans
quel but c'est pour la paix ça
m'étonnerait donc si la demi-heure
poutine a pris cette décision c'est
qu'ils n'avaient pas le choix son
objectif c'est la paix pour les
habitants du donbass et j'aimerais bien
qu'on parle en occident ce soir plus de
ses habitants de ces réfugiés qui
souffre depuis huit ans qu'ils n'ont
aucune aide aucune aide des pays
occidentaux et qui ce soir espère avec
cette avec cette décision de moscou
revivre en paix parce que du coup la
situation mais non la donne va changer
mais n'ont qu'à moscou on reconnaissait
cette indépendance et ces deux
républiques on est content